[موسيقى]
عالم الاجتماع اليهودي الشهير ميشيل
فيفيكا المتحدر من عائله ناجيه من محرقه
هتلر وصاحب كتاب القصه الاخيره لليهود
يقول المجتمع الاسرائيلي مريض لقد اختار
سياسيا مجرما مثل بنيامين نتنياهو والان
سيرتبط اسمنا بارتكاب
المجازر
الان لقد تقلصت المحاباه لليهود في العالم
يضيف بعد ان كانت رائجه بسبب ما تعرضنا له
في المحرقه النازيه الى
العناوين هل انزل حكم لهاي اسرائيل عن
شجره البلطجه
القانونيه كوب شاي يفرض اعتذارا امريكيا
من المملكه المتحده فماذا عن نهر الدم
الفلسطيني
نتنياهو يتهم الوساطه القطريه بالاشكال
وواشنطن تشكر
الدوحه سندويتش الشاورما التي هزت اسرائيل
مطعم 7
اكتوبر بعد حذاء السنوار نتنياهو يحتفي
بالعثور على كتاب كفاح في
غزه طفل جائع يطلب من العرب نصف رغيف اذا
تعذر عليهم ارسال رغيف
كامل جندي بدوي اسمه احمد قتل دفاعا عن
الاحتلال وذووه يصلون
عليه استقدام عمال هنود بدل الفلسطين ين
فهل ترسلهم اسرائيل الى
الحرب مرحبا قيل للكذاب احلف فقال جاء
الفرج نحلف ولم لا اما نتنياهو فلا ولم
يطالبه احد بان يحلف على شيء لقد حوله
طوفان الاقصى الى بهيته بطل عضيه ولمن لا
يعرف معنى هذه المصطلحات فه اوصاف كلام
نتنياهو اذا حدث واذا وعد او تعهد يقول
نحوي عربي بي بي يضع مقياسا جديدا للانسان
المحترم بان ينكر الاباده الاسرائيليه
للفلسطينيين وان يعتبرها موسم كرنفال شتاء
غزه في الوقت الذي نفذ فيه جنوده الدوافه
مجزره نوعيه جديده داخل مستشفى وبحق جرحى
ارتكبوا جريمتهم متخفين بثوب الطب
الانساني وبحجابها
[موسيقى]
خاصه اسرائيليه تسلل افرادها الى مستشفى
ابن سينا في مدينه جنين متنكرين بزي
الاطباء واخت ثلاثه
شبان اثناء عمليه الانسحاب فضح امر الوحده
الخاصه فهب فريق ثاني لنجدتها ما ادى
لاكتشاف امرها انتهى زمن الباطنيه والتقيه
والتوريه في السياسه الاسرائيليه وهذا جيد
لقد اصبح كل شيء على المكشوف لذلك لم تبحث
محكمه العدل الدوليه عن تصريحات
الفلسطينيين والعرب لاتهام اسرائيل بل
اكتفت بتصريحات قادتها عندما امرت محكمه
العدل الدوليه اسرائيل باتخاذ اجراءات
لمنع ومعاقبه التحريض المباشر على الاباده
الجماعيه في حربها في قطاع غزه استشهدت
بتصريحات مسؤولين
اسرائيليين قبل يوم واحد فقط من امر
المحكمه جدد وزير التراث لشؤون القدس
والتراث الاسرائيلي دعوته لضرب غزه بقنبله
نوويه وقبلها في نهايه العام الماضي اقر
رئيس الوزراء اسرائي بانه يجري محادثات مع
دول اخرى حول الهجره الطوعيه لسكان غزه في
بدايه الحرب قال الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق
يتسوك بانه لا يوجد مدنيون في غزه وهناك
تصريح الشهير لوزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
الذي وصف سكان غزه بالحيوانات البشريه
جنوب افريقيا انتصرت وانتزعت اعترافا
دوليا بان هناك اسسا لاعتبار ما ترتكبه
اسرائيل في غزه اباده جماعيه فلا يجب ان
نقلل من هذا الانجاز التاريخي بينما نجلس
نحن على مقاهينا وتصل قرقعه شيشنا الى
الاسكا تشدنا محاميه امريكيه مناهضه
لاسرائيل
اسرائيل التي عاشت منذ ولادتها الحرام
بحسب شيخ ازهري نحن لا نفتي عاشت فوق
القانون هل تعيش مرحله جديده بدات فيها
بالنزول عن شجره الدلال والبلطجه الدوليه
ترى المحكمه فيما يتعلق بالوضع الحالي ان
على اسرائيل وفقا لالتزاماتها بموجب
باتفاقيه الاباده الجمعيه اتخاذ جميع
الاجراءات تجاه الفلسطينيين في غزه وترى
المحكمه كذلك ان على اسرائيل ان تضمن على
الفور عدم قيام قواتها العسكريه بارتكاب
اي من الافعال المذكوره في الاتفاقيه
السياسي الاشتراكي اللبناني وليد جون بلاط
كان متوازنا في حكمه على محكمه العدل
الدولي فوصفه بانه حكم الحد الادنى وان
الطريق ما يزال طويله بيان شديد الصرامه
اطلقته الامم المتحده كشفت فيه الستار عن
جرائم اسرائيل في القطاع المكلوم ليصبح
الصفعه الثانيه على وجه تل ابيب بعدما
فاجاتها محكمه العدل الدوليه بصفعه اولى
لم تكن تتوقعها مدلله امريكا مكتب حقوق
الانسان التابع للامم المتحده طالب العالم
بوضع حد للعنف الاسرائيلي والتجاهل الواضح
للقانون الدولي مشددا على ضروره ايصال
المساعدات الانسانيه دون عوائق الى جميع
من يحتاجون اليها واشنطن التي لم تسم بعد
رائحه محرقه غزه والاباده الجماعيه
لسكانها تعتذر من لندن وتتراجع عن محاوله
تحريف اكاديميه امريكيه لوصفه الشاي
المحسوبه تاريخيا على الانجليز عالم مجنون
لا ينفع معه شاي ولا شيء رسمي من السفاره
الامريكيه لمنع حصول ازمه دبلوماسيه بسبب
اقتراح وضع الملح في الشاي نشبت معركه
الكترونيه بين رواد وسائل التواصل
البريطانيين
والامريكيين بعد ان صرحت عالمه الجزيئات
الامريكيه ميشيل فرانكل ان الحل الامثل
للتخلص من مراره الشاي هو وضع القليل من
الملح في الكوبي قبل احتسائه الفكره احدثت
رده فعل غاضبه غير متوقع قعه بين البلدين
وصلت القضاء والعلاقات الدبلوماسيه حيث
كتبت صحفيه بريطانيه قانونيه مهدده اعتقد
اننا سنخوض الحرب مره اخرى وفي محاوله
لتهدئه التوتر تدخلت السفاره الامريكيه في
لندن وقدمت اعتذارا بالنيابه عن ميشيل
وقالت ان الفكره لا تعبر عن موقف رسمي
للولايات المتحده وان الولايات المتحده لا
يمكنها ان تقف مكتوفه الايدي لان مثل هذا
الاقتراح الشائن يهدد اساس العلاقه الخاصه
بين
البلدين وفيما يتعلق بقطر انا لا اتراجع
عن اي كلمه قلتها
نتنياهو الذي سبق ان وعد ناخبيه بتخطي
اسرائيل عقده نهايتها مع بلوغها سن الثين
بعد اربع سنوات من الان يريد اللعب
باعدادات العالم وتوازنات السياسيه
نتنياهو يعتبر بتسجيلات صوتيه مسربه وقال
انه لن يتراجع عنها ان الوساطه القطريه في
صفقه تبادل الاسرى تمثل اشكاليه في وقت
تتهمه فيه عائلات الاسرى بتسريب هجومه على
قطر بنيامين نتنياهو قطر رعت عشرات
المصالحات داخل الدول وبين الدول
واتمتع اسرع عديده واشرفت على اجلاء مدنيه
وعسكريه دوليه في غير مكان وفككت اشكاليات
كثيره في المنطقه الا اشكالك ومن معك اعيت
من
يفككها اما بخصوص رفضك شكر قطر فان شكرك
امرئه نقيصه في حقه يقول لمعلم بهيج وكانت
القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه قد كشفت عن
تسجيل مسرب لنتنياهو خلال لقائه عائلات
الاسرى في غزه قال فيه ان قطر اكثر
اشكاليه من الامم المتحده والصليب الاحمر
وبان لديه خيبه امل من ان واشنطن لا تمارس
المزيد من الضغوط على الدوحه وبحسب
التسجيل المس فان نتنياهو اشار الى انه لم
يشكر قطر علنا لانها يمكن ان تمارس المزيد
من الضغط على حركه حماس بينما ينصب
نتنياهو نفسه وصيا على السياسات الامريكيه
في الشرق الاوسط يرد البيت الابيض على
تسريبات نتنياهو الاشكاليه مجددا شكره
لدوله قطر على وساطتها الرئيسيه في
محادثات اطلاق الرهائن في غزه المهم في
الموضوع ان المتحدث باسم الخارجيه القطريه
ماجد الانصاري لم يستغرب كلام نتنياهو
فبماذا وصف الانصاري تصريحات بيي بغير
المسؤوله والمعر لجهود انقاذ الارواح وان
كانت غير مفاجئه وقال الانصاري انه انه
اذا تبين ان التصريحات صحيحه فان رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي يعرقل جهود الوساطه
لاسباب سياسيه ضيقه بدلا من اعطاء
الاولويه لانقاذ الارواح مضيفا انه وبدل
الانشغال ب لاقه قطر الاستراتيجيه مع
الولايات المتحده على نتنياهو ان ينشغل
بتذليل العقبات امام التوصل اللا اتفاق
لاطلاق سراح الرهائن جميع افراد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اغبياء وبعض المسؤولين لا
تستبعد خيانتهم وتورطهم مع يحيى السنوار
في الاعداد لعمليه طوفان الاقصى هذا ما
خلص اليه رئيس لجنه الامن القومي في
الكنيس الاسرائيلي هلا بالنسبه لانه
الوزراء اغبياء لا خلاف حولها بينك وبين
بهيج وصلنا الى سياره العالم النووي في
ايران وقتلناه ولم نعرف ماذا يحدث في قطاع
غزه لم يستبعد رئيس لجنه الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي تفي كا فوجل وجود خيانه او
مؤامره اسرائيليه وراء هجوم حركه حماس في
السابع من اكتوبر ومساعدتها على الدخول
لبلدات غلاف غزه مشيرا الى احتماليه ان
جميع افراد الحكومه الاس اغبياء اتهامات
ومناقشات بين الاجهزه الامنيه والحكومه
الاسرائيليه داخل الكابينت الامني بين من
يتهم الاخر بالتورط في الاعداد لهجوم حماس
بالاتفاق مع رئيس الحركه يحيى سنوار
تصريحات الوزراء الاسرائيليين ورئيسهم
تدعم اتهامهم بالغباء بقوه شديده فهل من
الذكاء ان يقول وزير الامن القومي اتمار
بن كبير ان التوراه نصت على وجوب استيطان
اليهود قطاع غزه وتهجير سكانه الاصليين
واعدام المقاومين ويجب ان يكون الرد هو
عوده الاستيطان الى جوش قطيف يجب ان يتم
اعدامهم النخبه والمخرب وان نطبق ما نصت
عليه
راتنا وتشجيعهم على المغادره تشجيع اهل
غزه على الخروج
منها في محاوله ظهار التضامن مع القضيه
الفلسطينيه اثار افتتاح مطعم يحمل سن
السابع من اكتوبر جدلا سياسيا واجتماعيا
واسعا في اسرائيل وفي الاردن المطعم في
محافظه الكرك راى البعض انه تم اصطفائه
تخليدا لليوم الذي شنت فيه حركه حماس
هجومها على بلده غلاف غزه في عمليه طوفان
الاقصى المستوى السياسي الاسرائيلي دع الى
وقف ما سماه التمجيد المشينه لاحداث
السابع من اك اكتوبر زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه يائير لابيد وصف في تغريده له
عبر حسابه على منصه اكس هذا الامر بالمخزن
الحكومه الاردنيه بادانه هذا الامر على
الملا تصريح استهجن اهل الكرك واعتبره
السياسيون ونخب حزبيه اردنيه تدخلا من
لابيد بشان بلادهم اسرائيل علقت على سيخ
الشاورما منذ اكثر من اسبوع ولم تنزل عنه
اما من علقها فهو مواطن اردني بسيط فتح
مطعما للشاورما في الكرك واطلق عليه اسم 7
اكتوبر لتقوم تلبيب ولا تقعد حتى الان
استنكارات وبيانات وندوات تلفزيونيه تناقش
سندوتش الشاورما التي هزت اسرائيل فماذا
لو كان المطعم منسف
الياسين
ات اسم انتصار الغزاويه ال فلسطين عليكم
الاردني صاحب محل الشاورما رد بشكل مهضوم
يعني ظريف خفيف لطيف فقال ان السابع من
اكتوبر هو موعد تخرج ابنته من الجامعه اما
ملك المصلحه وعلى ما يبدو في محاوله منه
لتهدئه العاصفه نفى ان يكون اختياره لاسم
محله مرتبطا بهجوم حماس موضحا انه يعود
لتاريخ تخرج ابنته من الجامعه رفضت
التسميه من قبل دائره التراخيص وتمت ازاله
لافته المطعم فالتفتت انظار العرب اليه
وتبنت التسميه وتسميات مشابهه عده مؤسسات
وشركات عربيه وقريبا حول العالم الاسلامي
ربما يفت فتحوا مقه 6 1 اكتوبر ومصبغه ابو
عبيده ابن الجراح واذاعه الياسين
105 ميجا هرتز اف
ام بعد حذاء السنوار نتنياهو يحقق انتصارا
نوعيا جديدا بعثور جيشه في احد بيوت غزه
على كتاب كفاحي لهتلر الموجود بنص بيوت
القراء حول العالم فرفعه خلال مؤتمر صحفي
واتخذ منه تهمه لاهل غزه بمداه الساميه
نتنياهو الذي تفوق على هتلر في هولوكوست
غزه في التوصيف الفلسطيني
اني
يشم افتنا يا حخام الجليل سال جنود
اسرائيليون الحاخام
د هل يجوز ان ننتهك عطله السبت
اليهوديه الالزاميه من اجل الذهاب لمنع
دخول المساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه يجوز بل
يجب افتى لهم واذا استطعتم ان تمنعوا عنهم
الهواء فلا تتاخروا عن ذلك يوم السبت وكل
ايام الاسبوع دوف ليور ليس حاخاما من عند
جولي شيك بل هو الحاخام الاسرائيلي الاعلى
اصلي يعني ومنه نستفيد في فهم ماذا
يعتقدون وكيف
يفكرون
مشش
ل
ي
[موسيقى]
في غزه من نجى من الموت قصفا يواجه مجاعه
كارثيه ومرضا واوبئه تحت طقس بارد وممطر
يهدد حياتهم مع عدم وجود طعام والارتفاع
الهائل في الاسعار ما يصعب مهمه تامين
لقمه تسد جوعهم طفل جائع في غزه يطلب من
الامتين العربيه والاسلاميه نصف رغيف ورشه
زعتر وخيط زيت يا ابو الغيط ولا عننا نسفه
ال الحين طحين طول الليل واحنا جعانين
بالله بقيت جعان طول الليل وايش الصبح
اكلتنا فيس ولا هلقيت ما اكلت شي اه ايش
بدك تاكل اليوم طيب بعرف لس مش عارف اه
طيب ايش انت بتطلب يا حبيبي انا معك بس
شويه نص نص وهذا طحين واكل اه نص رغيف اه
فش الخبز من وين اجيب نص رغيف طيب ايش بدك
تحط في نص رغيف ايش بدك تحشيه لو جبت لك
اياه زعتر زعتر طب اكلت لحمه فيما تجوع
اسرائيل اهل غزه يدعو متصهين عربي مجهول
الجنسيه يدعو اصدقائه الاسرا ين الى
زيارته في بيته شرط ان لا ينسوا احضار
المقرمشات
الاسرائيليه التي يحبها سماجه الارض كلها
جمعت في 50 ثانيه وترجمها من العبريه
المترجم الفلسطيني احمد ابو غوش ولن
نعرضها الامطار تعمق ماساه النازحين في
رفح مع تشكيلها طبقه مائيه افسدت الخيام
والبطانيات ورفعت مستوى البرد لا سما عند
الاطفال كما تسربت مياه المجارير الى
الشوارع ما ينذر باوبه جديده تدمرنا احنا
مش حياه حياتنا هذه احنا اد نام تحت الميه
في المطر في الزباله في الدو الر القره
بلونا الخيمه هذ ايش بدها تحمي بتحمي شي
يعني ولا ليل ولا شي يعني شوف كيف يعني خي
شوف كيف تحت كل
غر في درس القواعد اليوم ما هو راب اعراب
العرب عن رعب من عربه يعبر عليها كبارنا
المرضى في غزه من خيمه الى
خيمه يا
ر ماء المطر ماء مطلق طهور باجماع المذاهب
الفقهيه الاسلاميه يصح الوضوء به استعدادا
للصلاه كما فعل هذا الحاج الفلسطيني بغزه
في ظل ازمه المياه في القطاع ما يحظى
باجماع العلماء ايضا تجريم وتحريم منع
الماء عن الناس النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام
نهى وحرم منع فضل الماء منع فضل الماء ومن
فعل ذلك فقد وقع في كبيره من كبائر الذنوب
لكن هذا الذي قطع السبيل ومنع فضل الماء
واذا المسلمين يمنعه الله عز وجل يمنعه
الفضل يوم القيامه الان من يمنع عن
المحاصرين في غزه الماء والغذاء والدواء
اسرائيل يؤكد الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح
السيسي انا هروح من ربنا فين لو انا
السبب لو انا السبب في ان انا
مادخلش لقمه عيش لا اقدر ادخلها لغزه اروح
من ربنا
فين لا والله مصر ماعبر رفح
مفتوح على مدار ال 24 20 ساعه في السبعه
ايام في 30 يوم انما الاجراءات اللي
بتتم من الجانب الاخر من اسرائيل عشان
نقدر ندخل الحاجه دون ان يتعرض لها احد هي
اللي بتادي لكده وده ده شكل من اشكال
الضغط على القطاع وسكانه عشان موضوع
الصراع اللي بينهم على موضوع اطلاق
الرهائن جندي اسرائيلي من العرب البدو
اسمه احمد لم يرضعه شيء عن قتل اخوانه في
الدين والوطن فقتل في غزه دفاعا عن
الاحتلال ذووه دفنوه على الطريقه
الاسلاميه وطلبوا لروحه الرحمه بل اعتبروه
بطلا في دفاعه عن دوله ينص قانونها على
انها دوله لليهود وليست للبدو شكرا كثير
كثير كثير ويب خمته ض خم يتفاخر بخدمته في
الجيش الاسرائيلي وايمانه بالتعايش مع
المجتمع الصهيوني ويلتقط صورا امام قبه
الصخره ليتباهى بها على حسابه في فيسبوك
الفلسطيني مجازا احمد ابو لطيف قتيلا في
صفوف جيش الاحتلال اللهم ان كان محسن فزد
في احساني و المسيف تجاوز عن سيئاته
واللهم ادخله الجنه يا رب العالمين عن اي
احسان يتحدثون وقد مات وهو يوجه فوهه
بندقيته ضد اخوانه في الدم والدين داخل
الى قطاع غزه تذكرون تلك المحلله
الاستراتيجيه الاسرائيليه نوجا اربيل كيف
دعت من الكنيسه قبل اسبوعين الى تدبير
وكاله الاونر وللتخفيف من اعداد الولادات
في غزه كما قالت من سخر منها عليه ان يوسع
هامش سخريته اليوم لتعبر المحيطات فعلى ما
يبدو ان اسرائيل وامريكا واوروبا مقتنعون
بنظرتها
التدميريه وقد بداوا بتبنيها عمليا في
سياق اسوا ازمه انسانيه يشهدها قطاع غزه
تدير عده دول غربيه ظهرها للفلسطينيين
بتعليق تمويلها وكاله الامم المتحده لغوث
وتشغيل اللاجئين الفلسطينيين استجابه
للدعايه الصهيونيه التي زعمت تورط عدد من
افراد الوكاله في عمليه طوفان الاقصى
وفيما توشك المساعدات الانسانيه في غزه
على النفاد اعلنت تسع دول غربيه على راسها
امريكا وبريطانيا وقف مساعداتها لوكاله
الاونروا مسلطه عقابا جماعيا على ملايين
الفلسطينيين نشر جيش الاحتلال فيديو يقول
انه لنازحين يطالبون باسقاط حركه حماس
نمتنع عن عرضه بسبب شبهه في فبركه تركيب
الصوت على الصوره اما هذا الفيديو لشاب من
غزه فصوته واضح ووجهه والاوض منهما موقفه
لنستمع اليه انا راح بيتي واولادي وابوي
واختي وكل الدنيا عشان اقول مقاومه انا مع
المقاومه من ه ليوم الدين في المطر وفي
الخيمه تبعتها الخيمه وفي المطر حضلي مع
المقاومه تحيا المقاومه طب ليش ليش لانه
هي تاج الراس هي اللي خلتني اني ابين انا
فلسطيني الجنسيه هي اللي بينتني هويه
الفلسطيني بينتني اني انا الوحيد اللي
تحديت دوله اسرائيل كل دول العالم من ال
67 لحتى الان فش حدا استطاع يتحد اسرائيل
الا كتائب القسام والمقاومه اسرائيل فتحت
الباب لمكاتب استخدام في نيو ديله بتنسيق
بين الحكومتين لاحلال العمال الهنود محل
الفلسطينيين فهرع مئات الالاف وقريبا
الملايين الى هذه المكاتب لاختيار 10 الاف
منهم على الاقل رغم المخاطر بعد طرد
العمال الفلسطينيين وهروب المزارعين
التايلنديين والنيبال اختار اسرائيل
العمال الهنود لاستبدالها عروض مغريه
لالاف العمال الهنود الذين بداوا
بالاصطفاف امام مكاتب التوظيف للحصول على
تاشيره تمنحهم وظيفه باكثر من 1600 دولار
شهريا مقابل حوالي 5 دولارا في بلدهم
المستقدم يعلمون بحسب التقرير انهم قد
يقتلون في اسرائيل بسبب الحرب فهل يتحولون
الى جنود مرتزقه لتكتمل طبخه الارتزاق في
جيش اسرائيل بالتوابل الهنديه خصوصا من
المعبئ اساسا في بلادهم ضد المسلمين
بتحريض من الجماعات الهندوسيه المتطرفه
المدعومه من رئاسه الحزب الحاكم المخاطر
التي تهدد سلامتهم بسبب الحرب المتواصله
بين اسرائيل وحركه حماس تبدو افضل من
الجوع في وطنهم اذا كان محكوم علينا
بالموت سنموت هناك على الاقل سيحصل
اطفالنا على شيء
وهذا افضل من الجوع
هنا اخيرا عبثا يحاول الاسرائيليون هزيمه
اراده الحياه عند
الفلسطينيين فهم كشعب مثل احلام الاطفال
لا يموتون يصيبهم نقص في الانفس والاملاك
لكنهم لا ينتهون فهل ينتهي من لا يفوته ان
يدعو اطفاله في خيام النزوح في رفح
لمشاهده فيلم سينمائي ترفيهي للرس
المتحركه ختاما روايه مارسال بروست البحث
عن الزمن المفقود هي الروايه الاطول في
العالم بمليون ووم الف كلمه كتبها بروست
وباسلوب بالغ الحساسيه يروي حكايه رجل
يبحث عن معنى لحياته ويعتقد النقاد ان هذا
الرجل هو بروست نفسه اما الروايه الاقصر
في التاريخ فهي في طور الكتابه تروي حكايه
شته شته وطنا ومحروق احرق بريئا وملاحق
لاحق امنا وضحيه خلفت ملايين الضحايا حتى
جاء يوم ظهر فيه قائد بعدل عمر وشجاعه
خالد واصرار صلاح الدين فعاد كل حي الى
حيه وزرع التين والزيتون من جديد الى
اللقاء حبك جزء من
ديني يا اقصى فاض
حنيني حبك جزء من
ديني يا اقصى فط
حنيني بالتين
وبزيت بالتين
وبزيت اقسم فيك الله صلى الله على من خصى
ان يسرج بالزيت
الافخم اتوه فصلوا فيه طه قد صلى
فيه اتوه فصلوا
فيه طه قد صلى فيه
هذا الاقصى
[موسيقى]
نحميه هذا الاقصى
نحميه كرم لرسول
الله صلى الله على من خصى
بالاسرى للحرم
الاقصى صلى الله على من اوصى ان يسرج بال
سيت
[موسيقى]
الافخم